not just to anybody I think it was like
something different like that it was
like pretty cool yeah but those apps
never worked because of molestation yeah
but then again he uh molested somebody
and uh that was that oh [__] hopefully
you get sporked in jail you know what
I'm saying
[Music]
it's for a 14 year old student who
invented a device that detects and
treats mid ear
uh let me just be clear about what that
is mid-ear infections right so it's like
in the middle of the year you know you
get an ear infection yeah but like
sometimes you can't quite reach it with
certain antibiotics oh really using this
um light that she invented oh it's alive
yeah she can kill the bacteria inside of
her ear whoa a 14 year old and she was
awarded this year's 3M young scientist
challenge grand prize from San Diego
California her name is Leanne fan
um why did I think Indian or Asian
because I'm racist she's Asian no that's
what I meant like Indian or Asian but
being right about it doesn't make you
less racist
so she calls them the fencing headphones
um after Niels fencing the Nobel Prize
recipient who discovered that
ultraviolet light can help treat
bacterial infections she named it what
the fence and headphones yeah the fence
and headphones she calls it beats by lay
he's my fan
she says every year 10 of the world's
population experience a mid-ear
infection most of which our children are
underprivileged people
um furthermore not everyone has access
to a doctor which makes it difficult to
diagnose and treat a mid-air infection
my solution to this is to create a
low-cost device that can both detect and
treat those infections how did she do
this research that's so insane well she
says she basically became a finalist
um from Shark Tank no no
sure
no she she doesn't say how she came up
with it she just I think followed the
Nobel Prize recipient's research and
then came up with a cool application for
it that also plays music
oh that's even better she made it even
cooler she says that um you put the
headphones on they play music she
personally likes to listen to BTS tight
behind the scenes this is kind of annoy
me and there are smart headphones too
which is cool and then the lasers inside
the headphones so the baby doesn't know
that it's happening and then the laser
clears up the ear boogers exactly the
lights just
see I wish I had that kind of smarts
what's her name Miss spam say her name
was it me and fan Leanne fan fam fam
with the m a fan
okay oh F not pH no like the appliance
oh like the appliance okay
it's Chinese fam what's fan fa animal it
says I think pH is Vietnamese yeah oh it
just says she's from San Diego oh she's
San Diego but she's really American but
she hears her wearing the headphones
it's pretty cute
dude good job
let's go she's a genius I also wish I
was a genius I haven't invented anything
cool you didn't invent anything
inventing stuff's like that's the
coolest thing you can do is to prevent
something and something and have it be
useful I was convinced I wanted to make
the retractable Spork one time
what is it where does it retract to well
so it's a spoon and then you just and it
becomes a sport but who really needs a
spork these days you know nobody
just like Devil's and have it be useful
I was gonna I was gonna make an NPC like
beat sampler you know when you go to do
but it was a steering wheel cover so
when you listen to music
but then uh fatalities I saw in my
dreams
hey when does anyone ever use a spork
and it's like pretty reliable it breaks
all the time don't [__] on his invention
well no I'm not really I'm not really
trying but if we had to pitch on how to
[__] on anything like how can we make it
how can we how about like try to come up
with one cool thing no no I just don't
think it is that word what's your
invention what's your invention
um oh it's a it's so what it does is
like you you crank this thing and it
destroys Sports when you put them in
yeah because like everyone's like oh
they're so useful already invented you
just grind that you just use this
grinder and then yeah also you're you're
an accessory to my industry that's so
sick dude it destroys Sports yeah that's
cool put your hand back up put it up
I'm taking it back
anybody else had any uh childhood
inventions I don't want to share it
because Steve's gonna [__] on me dude he
already made it he already went he
already went what's yours no I don't I
don't have anything I want to use uh
smart contracts for constructing
commercial properties to eliminate con
um
um corruption let's go and then
government middleman corruption yeah and
then uh so people are gonna leverage
those smart contracts and then it's over
dude like uh let's say
like let's say there's a there's like
tax money that gets collected right and
then we use the blockchain to see how
much went to this department and then
from there the smart contract for like
let's say building a railway gets
divvied up for whatever and then we see
what it's spent on so then we'll
actually have rail projects that are
finished
because I don't know why rail projects
never get done I kind of like that they
don't get them you do because if you
laugh at us kind of like a Charming
thing that is part of our society like
we get to [__] to our neighbors about
something together and we all get to
commiserate about it yeah and all of our
tax dollars go to it yeah yeah and but
we can't quite track it kind of like it
kind of like your cranes but oh where'd
all the tax money goes like I don't
really care and I shouldn't ask these
questions huh dude I knew you like the
mystery I knew a dude who invented this
app and it like got bought for millions
and it's uh what it did is it allowed
restaurants to all the restaurants were
using this app where at the end of the
day the surplus food that they could
neither uh sell or throw away they
listed it on the app and it got like
bought for uh services to like give it
to homeless or for like people that just
want to cheap food that's great and then
it would get collected this probably
wasn't in California it was yeah it's a
California thing but then uh true story
the guy went to jail for model station
way I thought well no because in
California you can't like they used to
do that where they would they had a
company that would round up like grocery
stores and like people who had like
donuts that were like they couldn't sell
anymore and they were trying to get into
homeless people and then the state
cracked down that [__] and like they're
like stop feeding them we want them
hungry yeah it's because of lawsuits
lawyers would wait and then like when a
homeless guy goes hey you're sick aren't
you yeah and then they basically sue the
state or whatever it is that's what this
app did is it gave uh certain permitted
services to get that food oh that's cool
it's not just to anybody I think it was
like something different like that it
was like pretty cool yeah but those apps
never worked because of molestation yeah
but then again he uh molested somebody
and uh that was that oh [__] hopefully
you get sporked in jail you know what
I'm saying that one is useful that's
when it attracted so yeah don't put him
in the grinder just sport them yeah
we thought it was good food no I go like
this with The Grater now I'm like it
goes
my bad I was wrong yeah there we go
no did you ever think of an invention
that would help make filmmaking easier
uh that would be innovating myself out
of a job
hey have you seen this [__] where
um you know how like they're making
Carl's Jr commercials and [__] and they
make like all the patties coming
together at the same time and it's like
the lettuce is bouncing around oh it's
great there's like a whole I watched a
YouTube video where this cat is like
talking about how his production company
like sets up uses Machinery to pull
those shots in and out I'm like it's
[__] bananas I thought of you I
thought you'd think okay yeah yeah those
are cool I love those things what about
a uh a Steadicam that's floating
no like a drony cam
it's just loud as [__] where it's not
like where it's not uh you're not you're
not holding it doesn't have to be yeah
human human operated well it does just
not human weighed down yeah
oh
um yeah we have those they're called
cranes
oh so why do we still have steady camps
different looks and how come they gotta
always also like maybe the scene you
need somebody to walk through something
that a crane can't get get past how
about this okay you ever been on set and
they set up those little tracks and they
have their dolly in the shot over but
then they hit a guy's shoe and they run
over a guy's foot you got a shoe now
that has a rail right there so now it's
all good it just it goes right over it
you're completely good that's amazing
and you're not missing shots the guys
just stands there it just rolls right
over and it's like all good it's like
soaps remember soaps how about an SD
card that already
is deleted
it's a dummy SD card that's really good
hey that's something new
and then it's already deleted and he and
then he can't do his usual deleting
thing he puts him out of a job he's
obsolete Innovative hey I don't feel
good about getting paid today because I
tried to drag and drop the footage into
the trash can it didn't work I don't
feel good I feel good about this
oh what did you call it pop lock drag
and drop
that was off camera but yeah Pop Lock
drag and drop
good branding you just only remember the
pop and lock part yeah yeah almost I
mean the drag well we can't we don't
remember the Dragon Bridge did you guys
know that zipper is like that's an
invention from one dude and that zipper
is the same zipper like on everything so
he patented yeah the patent his own so
the zipper family is like just
rolling and dope you know when you're
watching like like football and you see
the yellow line like which is like the
first down marker and you see like the
line scrimmage marker the blue line
that's some guy who owns that [__]
[__] same [__] he patented the along
with the technology yeah the technology
so like the way that it appears on the
field and how players can run over it
and like you don't it doesn't matter
[__] sick but it showed the line of
gain and it helps the game so much
because you can see what's like where
they need to get to so it actually has
helped the game visually so much that
yeah that's one of the sickest things
ever but that cat gets paid like 80 G's
a game it's like insane per game per
game like wow that was like the last
time I read about this was like eight
years ago so maybe it's more than that
but it's very renegotiation there's one
I think it was an Indian dude who
invented the um the pill capsule that
dissolves you know the one that whoa and
I only know this because uh when I was
doing this job for uh Circus Soleil back
in the day
um this one dude because he's so [__]
rich off of that hired Circ to come out
and do a private whole show for like uh
one of his adventures birthday or some
[__] and I was like who the [__] can
afford to have a whole search show for
themselves it's like oh yeah you're
[__] event to that and I was like
that's a good invention yeah that's a
good idea
mentioned geez does the average trip you
out that everything that is around us is
an invention from multiple people every
[__] day
I never thought of it yeah I can't wait
for that SD card that auto deletes
[Music]
foreign